I have a buddy of mine who hooked up
with this girl and uh,
they,
they went back and forth online and then
they got together and he said
immediately before she even blew him,
she went right to his ass.
I went,
what?
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
I just got off a plane,
fucking disgusting travel as
I'm like,
what?
He goes,
I was so disgusted.
I've never called her again.
I first moved,
went to the,
you know,
some ladies are bold.
Yes.
Yeah,
that's a weird move though,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What kind of message you're trying to
send.
Some chicks are just cool,
man.
Yeah man,
she's the best.
I mean,
how many guys have told their friends
that kind of a story.
And I'm like,
wow,
that's awesome.
So you found a good girl?
Oh my God.
Oh,
you don't want to do that Wolf Wolf.
Remember doing that?
Someone in college,
I only did it because I saw in a movie.
You know
what I did?
I got Hershey's Syrup and I thought it
was like Kinky to do that.
And then I realized as the Hershey
Syrup,
it just looks like she shit all over
because it's just liquid chocolate.
So I pulled my face up and
it looks like she just shit in my mouth
even though it didn't taste like it
looked like it.
Yeah.
That's not a good look.
I don't think she liked it either.
No,
she get weirded out by,
you know,
she was just like this.
But you want to do right,
man.